(hymne national ukrainien)
- L'hymne national ukrainien
résonne dans les rues
de Montréal.
(hymne national ukrainien)
Des gens se sont rassemblés
devant le consulat général
de la Fédération de Russie
pour démonter leur soutien
envers l'Ukraine, 10 jours
après l'invasion russe.
Au piano : cet Ukrainien
d'origine.
SERHIY SALOV, pianiste
d'origine ukrain
- Ma vie ne sera jamais
comme auparavant. Il y avait
avant 24 février 2022 et après.
- À Québec, lesxxxxx
ukrainiens aussi flottent
dans les airs. Olena vit
au Canada depuis 10 ans.
OLENA MARTYNCHUK, résidente
de Québec d'origine ukrainienne
- Moi, je ne peux pas expliquer
la douleur que chacun de nous
ressent. On essaie d'appeler
chaque jour juste nos amis
pour savoir si tout le m
est en vie.
- Ses proches sont toujours
en e e e e et ne comptent pas
la quitter.
- Ma mère est à Kiev
présentement. Il y a
beaucoup de gens comme elle
qui ne veulent pas partir.
- Elle demande aux forces
de l'OTAN que le ciel de
son pays soit mieux protégé
pour que les civils soient
en sécurit
- Si l'OTAN intervient, c'est
la guerre. Personne veut ça,
mais peut-être qu'il y a
un autre moyen d'aider
avec les avions militaires.
- Son groupe d'amis croit
que l'armée ukrainienne
est en mesure de se défendre
au sol, ma n n n n n n'a pas
la capacité d'arrêter les Russes
dans les airs. Cette situation
les paralyse. Oleksandra a tout
simplement arrêté de travailler.
OLEKSANDRA SOPILNIAK, résidente
de Québec d'origine ukrainienne
- On pense toujours à
nos proches. On pense toujours
à la situation en
IVAN OKACHA, résident de Québec
d'origine ukrainienne
- On écoute les nouvelles
toujours, à tous les jours,
à tous les soirs.
- Il n'y a pas d'autres choix,
selon eux, les décideurs doivent
durcir le ton au plus vite,
sans quoi les conséquences
seront désastreuses.
OLEKSANDR OKACHAM, résident
de Québec d'origine ukrainienne
- Si l'OTAN pense que la guerre
ne vient pas à l'Europe,
c'est une erreur...
c'est une majeure erreur.
- C'est aussi ce que pense
Oksana, arrivée au Québec
il y a six ans.
OKSANA GNUSHCHENKIVA, résidente
de Québec d'origine ukrainienne
- Et Poutine ne veut pas
arrêter juste en Ukraine.
- Comme tant d'autres,
sa famille est aussi prise
en Ukraine. Elle habite
à quelque pas de la centrale
nucléaire attaquée vendredi.
- Supporter ça, c'est vraiment
très, très difficile. Quand
tu comprends que peut-être
demain, quand nous allons
appeler... peut-êtr
aujourd'hui, c'est la dernière
fois que nous parlons avecnonon.
- De loin, ces Ukrainiens
regardent, impuissants,
les leurs avec fierté.
- On est encore Ukraine libre
et on va survivre, c'est sûr.
- Et ils espèrent que
leur message soit entendu.
Ici Marie-P
Radio-Canada, Québe